woman can love a man but not respect him
that's called the friend zone and you
will be friend zoned if you do that that
is the friend zone I love you but I just
don't see you as a guy that that's the
friend zone lack of respect lack of sex
drive lack of Desire lack of trust so
respect for men ultimately more
important Chris you are a respectable
guy I respect you but have you ever had
a woman actually think to say I respect
you have you ever had that most women
don't even imagine that it's important
yeah it's it's not something that I hear
many of my friends saying that they've
heard from their Partners I guess again
the sort of theory of cross- seex mind
reading thing the failure is well as a
woman why would I be but I'm not
bothered I want to be respected but like
the fact that someone respects me is I
guess mandatory on Route toward being
loved but it's not something that I
actually strive to have